feu celui-ci s'intitule tout simplement
et joliment feu talives très peu connues
même de vos lecteurs et c'est pourtant
le livre ou certainement vous vous avez
plus confié au fond c'est un livre de
poèmes sont des poèmes en prose ne sont
total des poèmes et envers les les cas
ne se précipitent pas sur des poèmes
oui mais je crois que c'est pas tout à
fait vrai que ce sont des poèmes
parce que d'abord il ya des récits la
famille réussies même soi soit on
présume intéressant à temps et c'est
vrai et c'est parfois l'île de moraliste
aussi faisait davis en libye certains se
tiraient une conséquence qu'il compte
d'une expérience vécue ce journal d'une
passion oui mais évoqué à travers un
total tout un groupe de personnages
variés on va qui parle dont on parle
tout bas que parfois elle là on entend
marquer tueur se marre
qui parle à la première personne kerry a
dépensé hills a fait entrer enfin les wc
mais qui se plaint qui gémit des fois
qu'ils aient leur chemin vous dites par
exemple l'amour est un châtiment
nous sommes punis de n'avoir pas pu
rester seul je ne l'entends parfois y'a
pas des freins excessive dans ce livre
mais ça me rappelle un peu la fin avec
un déficit de pascal qui disait que
l'homme est évident d'avoir passionnés
dans une charmante fille ça se ressemble
évidemment dès qu'on met le nez dehors
hors de sa chambre où dès qu'on
s'attache à quelqu'un d'autre on comme
certains risques et ceci par exemple un
coeur c'est peut-être malpropre c'est de
l'ordre de la table d'anatomie de l'étal
du boucher je préfère ton corps j'étais
très surpris vraiment dire ça sonne plus
et donc là je crois que je réagisse
contre la tendance france m excuser mon
manque de patriotisme ou sentimentalisme
amoureux est souvent apprécié que la
france depuis moyenne à lanfains fait
k23 et en passant blain princesse de
prêt avait un continent avec les romans
un type comme l'histoire duchesse de
langeais lynch est que c'est lui jusqu'à
nos jours a finalement un plat si j'ose
dire de l'amour qu'on a beaucoup trop
parlé du caire est pas ça c'est le corps
peut-être pas grand-chose à dire lui
concédant qu'il existe mais rien n'est
mieux que l'existant dit clair mais très
souvent secrètes et si artificielle le
nez tellement l'impression d'avoir été
en henry bahn et de littérature que je
me méfie toujours beau cette passion
vous raconter ce une passion très
douloureuse
enfin le centre sans jouer il ferait pas
des patients aux il ya parfois des
pâtures enfin bon alors pour moi et
alors la fin vous dit
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai voulu
dire qui mute était fade d'être
et pourtant vous êtes plein tout au long
du livre est fatigué alors jen
championne impatience qu'on voit 10e jeu
rapprocher sa d'une phrase d'une
infection d'alexis donc qui avait écrit
est facile et écrite je sais pas 15
avant alexis il est difficile de ne pas
se croire supérieur lorsqu'on souffre
davantage que la plupart du temps c'est
un coup dur et il n'est peut-être pas
tout à fait une illusion car enfin il en
bave pris certaines jalousies et vous
ajoutez enfin alexis ajoute et la vue
des gens heureux donne la nausée du
bonheur se savait menacé sous les gens
ne sont pas bien évidemment quand les
gens me voient sont très bien on est
heureux pour eux mais quand il sent
assez déplaisant oui c'est pas toujours
un joli spectacle
venons en à